this this one this question was quite
clearly trying to mess with you okay but
but if you are careful and methodical
bad and to be honest like sorry if you
if you're struggling a bit I know
there's a lot of trig identities to
learn right so it can get easy to
confuse them with each other you need to
settle it for yourself now that if this
was one that tripped you what then it's
showing that it's okay it's like you
kind of know them but you don't you
don't really know them well because
there's only really one way to go
through this there's not a complicated
okay but if you mistook it for something
else that's where you really had trouble
so what was the most easy thing to
mistake this for I'll show you like you
see tant you see tans you see a 1 plus
tan squared okay so your brain is
thinking your brain is thinking this
you're thinking oh I recognize this one
this is double egg and tan right and if
you start thinking about this fairly
quickly the problem emerges and this is
what I mean by if you know well you
wouldn't have meant you wouldn't have
mistook it right but you know details
you're rushing anyhow this is what would
happen you said okay to tan X I don't
have to shoot out the front but that's
no big deal this is the constant I can
fix that up in a second and then you'd
say divided by now pause if you remember
not only have we done known you know all
of the identities we've also gone from
those identities and we've taken them
elsewhere wheeler e angle off of all of
the sine and cos expansions and then we
learn T results off of this expansion
right so hopefully the chords are
turning and you should have remembered
that there's 1 minus 10 squared down
here on the bottom ok now as soon as you
see that you know that that's
disqualified for being useful for this
question because I'm not that's not what
you have here okay but of course you're
me rush and you're like yeah oh it must
be a plus right and then you get to oh
that must be tan fit half of 10:30 it's
not working for me what's going on so
this is what we should have done instead
this is a proof I have show that so
clearly you go stuff from one side and
then work to the other
the left-hand side is clearly obvious
one so I'm gonna go ten on one plus okay
now when you look at this now one plus
tan squared should be jumping out of you
especially when you've disqualified this
as an option let's say this is the
Pythagorean identity it's not one of the
more comfortable the common one is sine
squared plus cos squared equals one so
you buy now you recognize when you see
one minus sine squared you know what
that's equal to when you see one minus
cos squared you know what that's equal
to this one's less familiar so as I've
said my best strategy you know I try and
memorize as little as possible and just
remember where things come from right
because then you won't get them wrong
memorizing can really screw you over
as we saw right so this result is the
fundamental one and if I want to take
that and have it in terms of ones and
tan squares what do I divide by divided
by cos squared right so if I divide this
by closed squared it becomes tan squared
this becomes the one that I'm after and
what's over here on the right hand side
it's XA squared I should say so knowing
that I have SEC squared 15 degrees on
the denominator now just very mind
paying attention to the number of marks
that this is worth you don't you don't
need to have written down all of these
lines of working I just try to make the
logic clear
had I been solving this question and I
saw what it was worth I would pretty
much jump like two or three steps at
least because I can see what's going on
and I know based on the number of marks
I don't need to write it okay where am I
gonna go from here okay I've got Taylor
the top I've got sex squared on the
bottom now both of those are identities
they both had Diddy's in terms side good
cause so I'm going to rewrite under
those terms right so I've got sign on
cause that's my numerator right and I
divided by this thing over here which is
1 over cos squared right whatever closed
squared
Sabeena time divided by a reciprocal
what I'm really doing is multiplying by
what that denominator is so I'm
multiplied by cos squared which is why
one of these will cancel and I'll just
be left then is okay and this we should
recognize this we should recognize right
this is to put it again like this is not
a line of working I would write down but
just so you can see what my brain is
doing right this is half of double sine
15 right why did I bother putting a half
in a two at the front so that I can get
the double angle result in here two sine
x cos x that's sine 2 X right so I can
go straight to that same half of size 30
that's half of half which is okay so
this is like I keep saying this is far
more lines than I would have written for
the number of marks that are there but
you can see the cogs that were turning
in my brain for me to get there even
this part here right I admit the first
time I picked up this paper I looked at
it because I was there with you and I
look and I just did the mental
computation in my head for 1030 no so
that's not so 103 isn't it
how are you gonna get a quarter out of
that and then I realized I'd forgotten
this and I did this and I okay now I see
where it's going okay that's a part of
the wiki that's a part of the logic of
how I got there that's how I do it but
this isn't what's useful does that make
sense